dans les années 50 le chimiste and lee
miller va tenter une expérience avec
pour but de recréer la vie depuis zéro
avec de l'eau des gaz et quelques
électrodes
il arrive à reproduire des conditions
proches de ce qu'il s'est passé il ya
3,5 milliards d'années
résultat des premières briques du vivant
sont apparus au fond de son tube à essai
oui la vigne et d'une réaction chimique
et tout porte à croire que cette chimie
a pu se produire ailleurs dans l'univers
plusieurs mathématiciens ont proposé des
modèles algorithmique pour estimer le
nombre de planètes abritant la vie et il
y en a beaucoup
vous imaginez rien que notre galaxie
avec ses 100 milliards de planètes
statistiquement il ya forcément la vie
ailleurs tactiquement nous levant les
yeux vers le ciel vous regardez tic
civilisation plus avancé que la nôtre
alors pourquoi l'univers nous reste-t-il
à ce point silencieux pourquoi nous
captons nous pas la moindre preuve de la
vie vous allez voir avec la science se
faire visiter par des extraterrestres
est beaucoup plus compliquée qu'on ne le
pense très loin des clichés véhiculés
par hollywood
à quoi ressemblerait le signal d'une vie
extraterrestre déjà désolé de casser le
mythe mais il est probable que des
extraterrestres qui ont la capacité de
conquérir de nouvelles planètes nous
ressemblent beaucoup pas physiquement ça
pour être big pieuvre des limaces que
vous voulez non ici on parle du fait que
les lois de la physique étant partout
les mêmes
les aliens n'ont pas de pouvoirs
magiques ils sont limités par les mêmes
choses que nous c'est anthropocentrique
c'est de ce vent mais oui une
civilisation aliens devra aussi inventé
la roue et les moteurs à énergie fossile
pour communiquer à l'échelle d'une
planète
ils n'auront pas mieux que les ondes
électromagnétiques la radio la wifi
l'es5 j'ai tout ce qu'on utilise quoi on
ne passe pas d'une bactérie à des
moteurs à lévitation quantique 101 entre
2 et 7 entre deux c'est le nôtre
actuellement et il est assez silencieux
dans l'univers en 1974
l'humanité a quand même essayé d'envoyer
un signal de sa présence dans tout
l'univers c'est le fameux message
d'arecibo une civilisation
extraterrestre à notre niveau autant
forcément en capacité de décrypter les
ondes radio aussi ce qu'elle découvrira
pour par contre même moi je pige pas
donc je sais pas comment l alien mon
frère a malheureusement on n'a jamais eu
de réponse
en même temps le message n'a parcouru
que 0
00 09 % de la galaxie il lui faudra 25
mille ans pour parvenir jusqu'à l'âme à
des reculs où on soupçonne peut-être la
présence de vie et 25 millions
supplémentaires si jamais les aliens
veulent nous répondre l'humanité a aussi
envoyé des dessins dans une sonde
spatiale mais ça prendra des millions
d'années avant d'arriver à destination
et c'est un objet si petit qu'il n'ya
juste aucune chance qu'ils sont un jour
découvert si ça se trouve une sonde
spatiale alien comme la nôtre nous a
déjà frôlé et on l'a juste pas vu disons
le nous sommes des bébés dans l'univers
incapable de communiquer avec nos alter
ego l'astronome ruscart d'achève appelle
ça une civilisation de type 1 est une
civilisation de type 1 est limité à
l'énergie qu'elle peut tirer d'un
planète l'énergie la plus efficace qu'on
puisse y trouver c'est l'énergie
nucléaire mais même avec tout le stock
d'uranium présents sur terre on est à
peine capable de voyager un cinquième de
la galaxie sans compter les 8 millions
de tonnes d'uranium qu'il faut
transporter risque de manquer un peu de
place dans le vaisseau non en fait pour
les voyages interstellaires et nous faut
devenir une civilisation de type 2 et
pour ça une civilisation aliens devra
pouvoir collecter toute l'énergie de son
étoile car si on pouvait récupérer
l'énergie produite pendant une seule
seconde par le soleil on pourrait
subvenir aux besoins du monde entier
pendant 1500 ans et les scientifiques
ont déjà imaginé une technologie capable
de faire ça ce sont les sphères de dyson
des millions de milliards de panneaux
solaires en orbite autour du soleil et
construire ça c'est pas impossible mais
pour ça il faudrait déjà inventé des
robots autonomes capables de miner leurs
propres ressources et de se dupliquer et
ce à un infini et pour ça il est
probable que dans le futur l'humanité
doivent démanteler une planète comme
mercure pour construire une immense
sphère de dyson et c'est pas du tout de
la science fiction et ça existe
probablement déjà quelque part dans
l'univers vous vous en doutez une sphère
de dyson salesse de grosses traces bien
visibles dans le ciel
est ce à cause des oscillations de
luminosité de l'étoile que créent les
mii
deux panneaux solaires figurez-vous même
qu'en septembre 2015 des astronomes ont
découvert ce qui aurait pu être une
sphère de tyson malheureusement après
des mois de recherche on s'est rendu
compte que c'était probablement des
débris de gomme est relou la comète
d'une civilisation extraterrestre
peut-elle seulement atteindre notre
système solaire bon on va dire que nos
amis les aliens ont construit une sphère
de dyson comment à partir de là ils
peuvent rejoindre la planète terre le
plus gros des obstacles c'est le temps
voyager à la vitesse de la lumière c'est
physiquement impossible un simple grain
de poussière avec sa masse demanderait
une énergie infinie pour atteindre cette
vitesse et même 90 % de la vitesse de la
lumière
c'est déjà trop dangereux une simple
particules qui traînait tu seraient
pulvérisées
sans compter le temps d'accélération et
de freinage juste hors de proportion on
estime que la vitesse maximale théorique
que pourrait atteindre un vaisseau ce 10
% de la vitesse de la lumière
à cette vitesse une civilisation pour
est colonisé la totalité d'une galaxie
en à peu près 4 millions d'années le
temps de voyager construire une sphère
de dyson dans chaque système solaire et
s'étendre comme ça petit à petit c'est
ce qu'on appelle une civilisation de
type 3 pour que l'humanité ait atteint
ce stade il aurait fallu que nous soyons
déjà une civilisation de type 2 à
l'époque des dinosaures
or quand on regarde le ciel on ne voit
rien qui ressemble à ça alors peut-être
que c'est beaucoup plus loin que ça se
passe dans d'autres galaxies
peut-être mais on le saura jamais car
les autres galaxies sont vraiment trop
loin pour vous dire si on envoyait un
vaisseau à 10% la vitesse de la lumière
vers la galaxie la plus proche
andromède honorer le tente de
recoloniser la galaxie lui x 25 millions
d'années de trajet juste pour la blague
avec aux fusées actuel ça prendrait
trois milliards
demille à gagner de quoi regarder tous
les épisodes de one piece pendant le
trajet ouais en gros pour espérer
rencontrer une civilisation
intergalactique
il aurait fallu qu'elle soit
opérationnelle bien avant que les
dinosaures n'existe ça semble un peu
compliqué quand même
mais le pire c'est pour les galaxies
lointaines c'est juste impossible de les
rejoindre
et ça c'est à cause de l'extension de
l'univers car oui l'espace temps se
dilate de jour en jour c'est un peu
comme si vous étiez une grande nappe en
caoutchouc les éléments de sueur restent
à leur place mais ils s'écartent les uns
des autres et malheureusement certaines
galaxies s'éloignent de nous à une
vitesse supérieure à celle de la lumière
du coup notre petit message radio avec
son dessin moche se retrouvera un jour
tout seul
perdu dans l'infinité sans aucun espoir
de rejoindre une galaxie lointaine très
lointaine d'une civilisation avancée
peut-elle seulement survivre plus de
cent mille ans l'humanité existe depuis
presque 2,8 millions d'années pourtant
c'est seulement moins 3000 avec la fin
de la préhistoire qu'on voit apparaître
les premières civilisations en 5000 ans
on a fait énormément de choses mais
c'est finalement une très petite échelle
de temps dans 5000 ans aurons-nous
atteint le type 2 ou on ou disparus
plusieurs civilisations sont déjà tombés
à cause des guerres des maladies ou du
gaspillage des ressources naturelles
qu'est ce qui nous dit que notre
civilisation en dialyse et survivre à
plus de l'an et qu'elle ne tombera pas
comme les autres sont déjà tombés allons
encore plus loin peut-être sommes nous
les seuls êtres intelligents de
l'univers parce que nous sommes les
seuls à avoir passé ce qu'on appelle le
grand filtre la vie a plusieurs fois été
exterminés sur terre cause des
météorites ou des grandes glaciations
jusqu'ici on a eu beaucoup de chance de
son être relevé mais il y à un événement
spatiale qui pourrait mettre fin cette
petite fête
il est possible qu'un jour pour regarder
le ciel ni aveuglante et pouf toute la
ville sera désintégrer en un instant
c'est ce qu'on appelle un sursaut gamma
souffle destructeur venant de
l'explosion d'une étoile et que rien
dans l'univers ne freine pas même la
distance
peut-être qu'en ce moment même un
sursaut gamma se dirige vers nous mais
quand arrivera t-il dans 100 ans dans
mille ans dans un million d'années une
civilisation aliens et peut-être à
l'instant même
yves abhorré par un sursaut gamma et le
pire c'est que c'est loin d'être quelque
chose de rare dans l'univers
c'est peut-être ça qui explique pourquoi
on ne voit pas d' alien ils ont déjà
disparu
à moins que ce soit nous on n'a
peut-être pas encore la technologie
nécessaire pour les détecter
c'est une des nombreuses hypothèses de
enrico fermi pour expliquer l'absence
des signes de vie dans l'univers
c'est aussi possible qu'une civilisation
de type 2 ne puisse juste jamais existé
non pas à cause de la physique mais de
la psychologie qui même si elle sera
très différente existe chez les aliens
peut-être qu'à partir d'un certain
niveau de puissance une civilisation a
tendance à freiner son envie de conquête
on le voit aujourd'hui le monde semble
vouloir arrêter la folie des grandeurs
se regrouper autour de ses fondamentaux
protéger la nature qu'elle a déjà élevé
les conditions des fêtes plutôt que
d'envoyer les plus forts dans l'espace
c'est peut-être le genre de réflexion
qui finit par frapper toute civilisation
avancée
on ne peut pas le savoir c'est même
peut-être trop anthropocentrique mais
vous voulez partager cette petite
réflexion avec vous un grand merci à goa
pour l'écriture de cette vidéo c'était
un grand plongeon métaphysique qu'on
voulait faire avec vous j'espère que ça
vous a plu
si c'est le cas pensez à vous abonner à
la chaîne sayan frh on a fait la
dernière fois une vidéo sur l'hypothèse
d'une planète public vous conseille
d'aller là regardez c'est rigolo
en fait c'est sûrement une bonne chose
qu'on ait jamais rencontré d'alien si on
trouvait des traces de civilisations
extraterrestres d'animaux et même de
simples bactéries
ça voudrait dire qu'elle ne se sont pas
fait exterminer et que le pire pour nous
est à venir autant donc espérer ne rien
trouver et être les premiers à coloniser
l'univers merci nous avoir suivi pensez
à vous abonner à la chaîne c'est est née
Neoxys et Goa, aller tchao !